[Musique]
l'alsace les paysages ses vignes sa
culture mais aussi son tissu industriel
troisième région de france la plus
industrialisée les deux départements
alsaciens se hisse même sur la première
marche du podium pour le nombre
d'emplois dans les entreprises à
capitaux étrangers tournés vers
l'exportation notre territoire contre
quelques beaux fleurons ps adidas alstom
et bien d'autres mais ce tissu alsacien
n'est pas constitué que de grands
groupes la dynamique du theil toit est
aussi portée par de nombreuses pme
nous sommes dans la vallée de la thur
devant l'entreprise a zappé last 7 en
mai 2012 que trois entrepreneurs
audacieux créé cette entreprise de
chaudronnerie plastique ici on conçoit
et fabrique des pièces plastiques pour
de nombreux secteurs de points le
traitement de l'eau traitement de
surface aéronautique essentiellement
dans toutes les industries dans
lesquelles ils utilisent beaucoup de
produits chimiques ou très corrosif
c'est des choses assez pointue où il ya
toujours une notion de sécurité à avoir
à apporter parce que comme comme on
travaille avec des produits qui sont
très dangereux à la fois pour l'homme
est à la fois pour l'environnement
on a cette mesure de précaution a
toujours prendre en compte
aujourd'hui à da place compte une
trentaine de salariés ces carnets de
commandes sont pleins et l'entreprise
recrute
mais pour l'appuyer dans son
développement la société fait appel à la
dire à l' agence de développement
économique d'asie alors là dira nous a
mis en relation et nous et de avec
différents partenaires afin de trouver
des financements pour pour l'achat d'une
autre bâtiment pour l'achat de machines
et continuer ainsi le développement de
nantes de notre entreprise
comme dit nous on est pas on est on est
pas on n'est pas né gérant donc c'est
vrai que ça nous aide vraiment sur pas
mal d'aspects voici gens qui jouaient
talent chef d'entreprise dynamique qui a
pour mission de développer son
entreprise
cependant une tonne de questions se
pressent dans la tête de jean né en 2015
la fusion des agences d'économique des
deux départements alsaciens la dira
répond à une situation de crise pour ces
collectivités
en effet la réforme territoriale les
prive de la compétence économique
la fusion est alors le seul moyen de
préserver un outil à destination des
entreprises à l'échelle alsacienne après
deux ans d'activité dont les conseils
départementaux on est plus que jamais
convaincu que l'alsace et le bon
périmètre pour travailler sur le
développement économique
il faut à la fois de la proximité les
chefs d'entreprise ont besoin de
connaître leurs interlocuteurs à voir
qu'ils aient un lien de confiance qui
s'établissent entre l'interlocuteur et
le chef d'entreprise pour pouvoir
travailler ensemble les projets de
développement c'est la bonne échelle on
le voit bien aujourd'hui maintenant avec
le recul des deux dernières années pour
faire du réseau réseau entre les
entreprises parce que l'enjeu c'est pour
les entreprises à la fois de leur
trouver des fournisseurs de leur trouver
des clients et donc cette échelle répond
bien
à la demande c'est aussi une bonne
échelle parce que la particularité de
l'alsace c'est que chaque bassin
d'emploi apporte une dynamique à
l'ensemble du territoire
créateur et fabricant éponyme du célèbre
chariot au tournant des années 2000 10 k
10 connaît des difficultés graves
redressement judiciaire en 2012 jusqu'à
la faillite en 2014
c'est l'heure de la reprise que son
actuel pdg fait la rencontre des agents
de la dir qui est alors une structure
exclusivement par e-mail
l'adira c'est comme une boîte à outils
vous les appelez quand vous avez des
soucis ou quand vous avez besoin de
contacts et pas forcément d'ailleurs
quand vous avez des soucis quand vous
avez besoin de de trouver des solutions
notamment pour un agrandissement pour
trouver des financements n'a été mis en
relation avec les élus des élus nous ont
été dans dans plusieurs choses notamment
même à la reprise à la barre du tribunal
tout le monde était derrière nous pour
reprendre pour reprendre qu'à 10 donc
j'ai repris mois en 2014 fin 2014 avec à
l'époque uniquement 128 salariés
malheureusement et aujourd'hui je suis
plutôt heureux de vous dire que nous
avons 245 salariés alors qu'elle aurait
pu ne jamais fêté ses 90 ans en 2018
l'entreprise se porte bien et innovent
l'avenir kadi comme le chariot connectés
qui reconnaît vos achats et vous fait la
facture si la dirar est un outil majeur
pour soutenir les entreprises
l'agencé loin d'être le seul levier dont
disposent les conseils départementaux
réseau routier aménagement du territoire
politiques d'emploi et d'insertion
soutien au très haut débit
autant de compétences qui si elle ne
touche pas directement à l'économie
façonne l'environnement immédiat des
entreprises aujourd'hui je fais de
l'économie tous les jours je rencontre
sans cesse des chefs d'entreprise qui
ont des projets qui viennent me voir en
me demandant quelles sont les
interlocuteurs les partenaires qui
peuvent les aider je vois tous les jours
aussi des chefs d'entreprises qui
viennent me voir en me disant comment
est ce que je peux faire je cherche de 3
10 50 100 salariés
ou est-ce que je peux les trouver sur
beaucoup de sujets sur la vie
quotidienne sur l'urbanisme
on va être un soutien majeur
pour le dynamisme des entreprises et
donc l'écosystème de l'entreprise
c'est notre quotidien de sorte à
consolider le tissu économique existant
à rendre attractif notre territoire moi
mon ans je sais que l'alsace soit une
terre promise de l'entrepreneuriat
seul l'avenir nous dira si l'alsace
deviendra la nouvelle jérusalem du
business
reste que dès à présent ceux qui ont
fait le choix d'y établir leurs
activités y trouvent un environnement
propice on a encore la chance d'avoir
beaucoup d'industries notamment des
industries chimiques chez nous en alsace
et c'est autant de clients potentiels
parce que dès qu'on a affaire à une
l'utilisation de produits chimiques
on aura affaire à de la chaudronnerie
plastique pour justement sécuriser
l'environnement de travail des
opérateurs
elsa c'est important pour nous d'abord
on est là on a toujours vécu ici
donc ça veut dire tout notre savoir
faire est ici c'est ici qu'on sait faire
et on fabrique même nous mêmes nos nos
outils et nous et nos machines certaines
fois donc tout est ici et on va
continuer à produire ici dans une
économie globalisée quelle place pour un
sentiment d'appartenance alsacien au
sein des conseils départementaux on
souhaite en tout cas réconcilier
identité du territoire et rationalité
économique pour les deux exécutifs
l'alsace loin de l'être qu'un supplément
d'âme est un espace économiquement
pertinent qui gagnerait à retrouver
réalité institutionnelle
nous pensons que le dynamisme
développement économique de l'alsace
doit être ancrée dans l'espace rhénan la
chance que nous avons en alsace c'est
d'avoir des voisins qui sont le bade
wurtemberg et la suisse du nord-ouest et
ce sont les deux régions les plus
prospères économiquement en europe
ça a tout son sens quand on s'ancre à
cette échelle là pour générer une
dynamique de développement encore plus
importante 3% de chômage 1 seulement
dans le dans le bade wurtemberg là où
dans le bas rhin nous sommes à un peu
plus de 8
l'alsace demain si elle retrouve sa
compétence économique pourra travailler
de manière beaucoup plus étroite avec
l'allemagne et avec la suisse c'est
quelque chose qui est à construire et
qui pourrait faire levier encore plus
fortement de développement sur le
territoire alsacien
si les deux départements alsaciens opère
d'ores et déjà un rapprochement dans de
nombreux domaines
seule une évolution institutionnelle
l'heure
d'aller plus loin dans la politique
économique les enjeux et en nombre et
complexe il n'est pour l'heure pas
possible de dire si cette ambition se
concrétisera